Now, from my point of view, I'm an oncologist, which is a clinical oncologist,
and it's been a bit of a problem because I've been dismissed when I've said sensible things,
however he's any academic doctor. But these people forget that I did, I was there at the beginning
with HIV, and I was there in 1984 when Fauci promised a vaccine in 18 months time and thought 40 years
later we still don't have it. So I've been through all this, and I found the, as a co-discoverer
of the CD4 receptor, which is how I got involved in COVID in the first place, that my colleagues
collaborators with whom we'd actually done a very good HIV vaccine, and it's so we've published
everything on it, Fauci continued to ignore it for reasons. I've only just started to realise more
recently, but we are asked to help do a vaccine along the same lines. And my first thing with vaccine
less is more, the less she put into the vaccine, the more likely it is to work, and everybody went
for the spike protein. Now, when we analysed the spike protein, we found it had, and we wrote this all down,
we had terrible trouble publishing it, we couldn't publish it for three months, it was turned down by every
every journal. We found out there were six inserts plus the fewer in cleavage sites, and the importance
of this is these inserts all gave the virus a charge of a pH of 8 as opposed to normal 6, which meant it was
highly charged and acted like a fridge magnet going on to the fridge, really hyper-effectability for
human cells. The second thing that we did was blast analysis, and we pointed out the spike protein
had 80% homology to human epitopes, and some of these were virtually 100% like plate de facto
fall, which would give you horrible plotting issues, and violent, which would give you gillian
burray, etc. All these things had turned out to be true. We prepared a document, we gave it to our
government here, through go, I know it was disgusting, cabinet went to sage, witty and balance, and they all
decided to ignore it, so that's where I came from, so I was furious about that because we knew there
would be significant side effects. It was just how bad would it be? Well, instead of all, we know that we
had the problems, and Peter was the first to call the myocarditis stroke problems, etc, and others
came out with a variety of things, and when it started to roll the vaccine down to their 50s and 40s,
I mean, I protested and went berserk when they just suggested giving it to children, when it was
the average age of death was 82. I mean, the whole thing was like dystopian or well-earned nightmare,
we were descending into, but what brought me into this group very much was the boosters, and I've
done a lot of work in vaccines over the Institute of Cancer Vaccines in immunotherapy, which are a
principal law, and we have an adage that a vaccine needs a booster, it doesn't work, come on,
that my goodness, does that never be more true than in this case? And patients who have been given
these boosters, which I said were boosted in the gains of virus that left the planet, at least the
year ago, and because it was a cocksacky virus, anybody who's read the history of cocksacky virus
development knows you get a thing called antigenic sin, or immunological imprinting, so it doesn't matter
how many variants you vaccinate against the immune system only sees the first virus that's disappeared,
so it just produces lots of useless antibodies, but more importantly, the booster suppresses the
T-cell response, and that's where I came in. I started to see my melanoma clinic, patients who've
been stable for years, who suddenly came in, relaxed, sometimes the relax was quite vicious, I mean,
they had very bad disease, we had to retreat them all over again, and the only thing they had in common,
we're used to severe depression, divorce, death, bereavement, et cetera, suppressing the immune system
and losing control of the cancers, but none of my patients had this whatsoever. They'd all been
bullied by their GP's to have a booster just to be safe, and then I found that there are a lot of
people coming down, lymphomas, leukemiers, all of them had the booster, and I had three friends who
only had the booster so they could travel after being locked down for two, three years, all three of
them are relaxed and two of them are died, so we couldn't even treat these cancers, that was the
other big, they didn't even respond to the standard treatment, so that is why I've got really,
really vocal, I believe that using messenger RNA technology for infectious disease is basically a
gross medical negligence, it really is this criminal negligence, now knowing what we do, and it's
even worse than fact that every time I've raised it and raised it, with everybody having
carpeted by the hospital, being carpeted by the Royal College of Physicians, told to be quiet, and
I'm upset in the patients, and I said no, I'm not upset in the patients, I'm doing my job, first
do no harm, and I am not the canary of the gold mine, I am seeing harm, we must stop now, so I'll just
leave that as my, my message should be stopped there. Dr. Douglas, are other, I'm cold just seeing what
you're seeing, you can't be the only one, are they talking to you? Well, first of all my
own oncologists in my hospital were horrified and told me to be quiet, but I was upsetting their
patients, when I published my concerns and documented and said it actually fits because you're getting
T-cell suppression, you're getting immunoglobulins switched to tolerisation, I got contacted from
oncologists all over the world, from Australia, from South Africa, from America, from Canada, South
America, Europe, they all said the same thing, and they all said that they were told it was just
coincidence of our selection of anecdotes and to be quiet, that this is what the problem has been
with this pandemic, it is being all well-earned control and denial of the facts, and the total
prevention of debate, science is debate to become to the right conclusion, so following the science
or scientific consensus, these are complete in this moment, they are absolutely incredible that we've
had to put up with this, I've had plenty of doctors come up to me and said I would love to do what
you're doing, I would love to join you, but I've got a mortgage and two kids at school I have to put
through, that's what's been going on, but they've been going for the doctors that speak out, I don't care
because I'm passed by retirement age, so that's why I have no palms whatsoever in shouting.
So one of the things we're definitely witnessing four years into this now is again, government censorship,
myself written more than six-year-old site letters to our federal health agencies, they're not
responding, exactly, they have certain way they analyze veils, for example, first of all they
ignored the safety signals, screaming at them at veils, they do certain analyses on there, they won't
release those to the public, they won't release those to us, so we're not going to get the truth out of
governments, I think that's true globally, maybe a few jurisdictions might be a little more honest,
so things you've had other doctors contact you, they don't necessarily have to put their name to it,
but is it possible for people like you or a group to have doctors submit, you know, basic their
practice data that would show increases in cancers, would that be a possible effort that we can
undertake? Then all of a sudden, people I could ask and I do know, some of the people with the best
data are really bright clinical researchers who've got most to lose, I mean, one of the guys who
was joining me, he basically had a phone call from the top saying, if you do this, you will never get
another NIH grant ever again, that is the level of coercion that's been going on, that is his
likelihood, it's just incredible, I hear this all the time, the threatening coercion, this is not a
free and fair democratic society being living anymore, and we cannot allow it to continue like this,
this is something we really have to put back in the bag and never let out again.
So I want one of the questions you are going to want me to ask you is what should local government do
in the Channel Islands? What would you ask that they do? The first thing that I'd ask they do is
ban all messenger RNA vaccines, ban a whole concept to give him a booster, which is only do,
I mean, there's no way in the world these vaccines prevent infection, we know that from the
Cleveland study, many other studies, and more vaccines, the more likely you are to get COVID or some
other dreadful infection or disasters, bells, poles, the shingles of other sites, it's just so
obvious to any doctor, let's let's see all this, so that my first recommendation, ban all messenger
RNA vaccines for the future, ban all boosters here and now. But you understand one of the reasons that
they continue to push the boosters, that's one of the techniques, so they never have to emit
the Iran. If they all of a sudden ban the boosters of vaccine, that's a tacit admission that these
things were not safe, they were not effective, so all the lies you've been telling us for years
will be exposed. I mean, you understand that, right? Yes, well, when I was at Andrew had had several
parliamentary meetings, and I had discussed with somebody at one of these meetings, I didn't know exactly
he was, but he seemed to be very high up, and I said, why are the earth, is the government pushing
these boosters? And as coldly as you could like, he just said, well, there's been such a function
ordering far too many, they feel they ought to use them up. Now, it's even knowing that they're causing
severe harm, it makes the whole thing even worse. Have you been following the revelations of
other DNA contamination, a different type of DNA contamination? Is getting the cells, is getting the
nucleus, and how that might impact increasing cancer rates? Are you following that at all? Certainly
I have, and I've been writing in the day, skeptic, and the conservative woman actually wrote one
only yesterday on the day before on, where I listed all the ways that a messenger RNA booster vaccine
can cause cancer. It's now up to eight major described mechanisms, and the most recent one
is worth pointing out is, and Ryan and Cole know very much about this, is that the early studies
suggesting the spike protein bound to P53, Bracker, and MSH, etc, which are suppressing. So if you
inactivate these, you can't control cancer, you're basically taking the police out, as it were, has
been completely confirmed by a study from Brown University, where they show it's absolutely true,
and that's another thing. This was shown a couple of years ago, but it was withdrawn and retracted,
and the severe pressure from the NIH and big pharma companies. This is what's been going on,
it's unbelievable. Now, that binding of those suppressigings could lead to, to some of
the cancer in the next few years, because if you've got an abnormal vanity in the suppressing,
you end up with cancer 10, 20 years early, and then you know you've had it. So I'm really frightened
what the implications are for this, but the contamination issue you've brought up means that there's
no quality control. I mean, the MHRA go on about the importance of quality. They have made it very
difficult for a very safe procedure, they've made a heat kiln. Mike, back to hearing thing, I've
been working on with no side effects at all, but there's been shown in randomised studies to be
beneficial. They have stopped it being approved, because they keep bringing up safe issues, and quality
control. There were no quality control safety issues, as we know from this contamination in the
batches. I saw that that's a presentation out of the studies. It's absolutely important. As soon as
that became evident, they should abandon it. Have you seen the stories where government officials and
the people in charge have been attributing the terrible cancers? Some people are calling them
to accelerated aging. Do you want to comment on that? Yeah, well, yes, there's no doubt. There are
check-turbo cancers and accelerated. I've seen it myself. I've seen it to this week. I tried to
very little new practice, but both patients and new patients I saw this week basically had relapse
and turbo cancers. I eat very fast, and again, I mean, it's terrible. Can you tell me what vaccine is
in the industry? They both had not one booster, but two boosters, bullied by their GPs, well,
them just to be safe. Just to be safe. So many ways it could cut the term, because it unregulates
PDL1, which means you're protecting lachuma. I mean, we try to attack that and down-regulate it with
the latest immunotherapies, these contruders and octavos, etc. But it actually is activating pathways
that program to escape immunotherapy and chemotherapy. And I've seen that in my own patients,
I can't believe that their tumors didn't respond to standard treatments, and I knew it as due to
the spike now. I know you're a lot more reasons why.